bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission grands reportages
comment lutter contre la prostitution
faut-il la légaliser l'organiser la
réglementés comme c'est le cas en
allemagne et aux pays-bas ou bien tenter
de l'éradiquer de l'abolir en punissant
par exemple le client comme le fait la
suède et comme veut le faire le
gouvernement français celle des balles
europe hebdo débats parfois violents
entre les abolitionnistes d'un côté et
les réglementariste de l'autre nous
irons en suède le pays où la
pénalisation du client est en route
depuis 1999 et vous allez voir là-bas
des policiers passent leur temps à
traquer les clients des prostituées dans
les rues de stockholm pour les
verbaliser c'est le modèle suédois un
modèle dont la france veut s'inspirer
mais avant un tout autre sujet la
centrafrique
si la france et les autres pays
africains n'étaient pas intervenues
c'était la guerre civile dit oh du côté
de paris la france qui sent un peu seuls
les demandes des renforts à ses voisins
européens
et voilà le débat sur l'europe de la
défense
relancée
après le mali c'est la deuxième fois en
moins d'un an que françois hollande va
son uniforme de chefs de guerre et lens
l'armée française dans une opération
destinée à rétablir l'ordre en afrique
certes le président a pour ce faire la
bénédiction internationale que lui
confère la décision du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu
mais l'appui de la communauté
internationale et en particulier de nos
partenaires européens s'arrête là certes
2500 soldats de différents pays
d'afrique sont sur le terrain aux côtés
des 1600 hommes dépêchés par paris mais
les troupes de la miss kha les troupes
africaines
si elles ont reçu l'ordre de leur
commandement d'assurer la neutralisation
des bandes armées se sont jusqu'à
présent contenté de garder des bâtiments
et de faire des rondes en laissant le
travail ingrat et dangereux de
désarmement des milices à la france il y
a déjà perdu deux de ses hommes
si la france est intervenue en
centrafrique nos partenaires européens
eux jouent toujours aux abonnés absents
certes les anglais ont promis quelques
moyens de transport mais leur soutien
s'arrêtera là les allemands eux jouent
leur partition sur le thème on ne nous a
rien demandé
quant à l'europe du sud italie espagne
pourtant directement intéressés par ce
qui se joue de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée l'europe du sud
elle semble hors du coup à leurs
questions en centrafrique
et en ce qui concerne la défense
l'europe pourrait-elle démissionner
voilà l'europe pourrait-elle
démissionner alors nous a rejoints sur
ce plateau nicolas gros verheyde bonjour
vous êtes tout journaliste spécialisé
auteur du blog bruxelles 2 à qui nous
dit tout sur l'europe de la défense lors
première question toute simple pourquoi
la france est seule pour l'instant sur
notre terrain en centrafrique elle
assure quelque part aussi la sécurité
des européens mais votre le sujet de 10
bien la france et seuls un peu parce
qu'elle l'a voulu et aussi un peu parce
que les européens n'ont pas vraiment
voulu s'engager aux côtés de la france
où voir ou qu'aujourd'hui les chaque
pays a ses problèmes il y en a qui ont
des élections il y en a qui ont des
problèmes financiers
il y en a qui ont des problèmes
constitutionnels et puis en a qui
veulent pas y en a qui veulent pas être
alors pourquoi c'est pourquoi les
européens sont pas sur le terrain est ce
que c'est un problème financier ce que
c'est un problème ce que ça me manque de
volonté politique ou est-ce que manque
de capacités militaires aussi il y à
tous je dirais que là l'europe avait un
moyen qui s'appelle le battle group qui
est une force de réaction rapide légère
avec deux mille hommes elle est dirigée
actuellement par les britanniques
donc les britanniques ne veulent pas
d'europe de la défense surtout pas de
soldats sous drapeau européen ils
veulent bien tout faire mais en
bilatéral donc ça a été non de londres
et la haute représentante catherine
ashton a stoppé tout était prévu c'est
ça commençait le planifier l'envoi d'un
battle group c était stoppé une force de
rester une petite force de réaction
en fait c'était l'équivalent de ce que
les français envoyés donc ça veut dire
qu'on aurait doublé les forces sur place
au lieu d'avoir géré 1600 hommes on en a
eu trois quatre mille c'était ce qu'il
fallait ce moment là les britanniques
ont dit non pour les boîtiers nikon
oignons parce qu'en fait ils ne veulent
pas ils ne veulent ils estiment que
c'est l'otan qui est le gardien de la
sécurité en europe et il estime qu'il
n'y a pas besoin d'europe de la défense
voilà c'est une position idéologique
politique précise à cela s'ajoute la
réalité c'est que
les britanniques ne veulent pas le dire
mais ils sont épuisés par l'afghanistan
ils ont plus un sou et pour l'instant
les opérations si elles se font à
l'extérieur elles se feront à sous conté
et on verra donc là par exemple pour les
français ils prêtent facilement un c-17
ou deux mais c'est beaucoup moins que ce
que vont fournir les belges et les
allemands
même s'ils ont été les plus rapides donc
on l'a dit la france a demandé à un
concours plus solide plus fort de ses
partenaires européens pour soutenir
l'intervention en république
centrafricaine laurent fabius aurait
obtenu gain de cause il l'a dit aux
questions au gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale je vous propose de l'écouter
vous réagissez juste après
je crois pouvoir vous affirmez compte
tenu des démarches qui ont été faites
par la france que nous aurons bientôt
des troupes au sol qui seront apportées
par nos collègues européens
voilà des troupes au sol apportée par
nos collègues européens le dit texto de
quelles troupes s'agit-il
est-ce que c'est pas 2 prématurée le mot
bientôt est important raconte y joue
c'est pas aujourd'hui c'est le mot pour
ce que l'on sait en fait tous les
européens qui ont été testées ont
apporté ce qu'ils avaient promis ses
dires des avions donc on a là on a pour
résumer le royaume uni l'allemagne la
belgique et la pologne
le on parle de troupes au sol
les troupes au sol il ya deux ou trois
pays plusieurs pays ont été testés il ya
la belgique et la pologne
ces deux pays n'ont pour l'instant pas
donné une réponse du moins ferme
ils ont des procédures internes ils ont
aussi l'engagement de fesnojiv
privilégié pour des queues de
déconsidération de langon 6
on parle notamment parce que et puis il
ya une certaine habitude aussi à
s'entraîner en commun etc
bien sûr et c'est une région qu'elle
connaît bien qui est quand même très
proche de la région des grands lacs
mais justement ça pose problème pour la
belgique donc et la belgique est
d'accord ou pas alors la belgique n'a
pas encore donné son accord et il n'y a
pas eu de discussions la belgique et en
coalition au pouvoir une coalition
gouvernementale c'est pas parce que
éventuellement un ministre peut être
d'accord que l'ensemble du gouvernement
est d'accord
d'autant plus que l'engagement de
troupes terrestres de combat dans un
pays proche de la région des grands lacs
ça pose plus qu'un problème politique à
la belgique donc saab sans doute ça
pourra être fait un moment donné mais du
moins d'après les informations qui
remontent n'a pas encore été totalement
actée et côté polonais le premier
ministre l'a dit il ya quelques jours
c'est oui pour l'avion de transport pour
le reste on verra pour l'instant on est
en afghanistan
donc ça veut dire qu'en gros quand ce
sera un peu retiré d'afghanistan c'est
possible c'est pas un nom c'est on va
dire un oui de principe mais plus tard
donc le bientôt de de laurent fabius est
peut-être un peu plus tard un peu
exagéré c'est pas exagérer je pense que
laurent fabius force de la main on joue
j'étais que je joue pour pour
effectivement forcé un peu les européens
agir c'est vrai que là quand même il ya
un sérieux problème on n'est pas au la
question du centrafrique et pas juste
une question d'aller voir s'il fait beau
un peu plus loin on efface quand même un
massacre des massacres le mot de
génocide était prononcé un peu
rapidement mais mais même la commissaire
à l'aide humanitaire kristalina
georgieva qu'on a rencontrée elle dit
qui est très très prudents ces
terminologies dit la question d'un
génocide n'est pas purement hypothétique
donc on est quand même dans quelque
chose qui est d'une dimension totalement
différente que d'autres crises
l'autre crise en 2005 2007 si je ne
m'abuse j'avais une opération sous
bannière européenne
or for tchad et république a enfin
traduit pourquoi il n'y a pas une deux
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser
on avait cet instrument là il était
disponible le monter une opération prend
du temps donc ça c'est l'opération pour
avoir lieu maintenant
pour l'instant rien n'est prévu le
problème c'est que les ailes et les mini
des affaires étrangères se sont réunis
aussi quelques jours il n'y a rien eu de
on n'a pas demandé aux services de
plancher sur cette scène question là on
a demandé de réfléchir sur toutes les
options générales et éventuellement un
jour et c'est donc ça veut dire qu'on
est là on est à la veille de noël
ça veut dire que ça sera pas fait sauf
si un mandat très fort ça va pas être
fait tout de suite que c'est là l'erreur
de l'europe de la défense aujourd'hui
c'est quand il ya une demande
quand il ya un consensus international
parce que c'est ça ces deux cas sur le
centrafrique que tous les pays africains
sont d'accord ce qui est différent de la
libye par exemple les européens sont
incapables de mettre en oeuvre ce qu'ils
ont dû disponibles je parle même pas de
ce qu'ils n'ont pas disponibles ce
qu'ils ont disponible est prévu pour ça
et le nerf de la guerre les choux est ce
que c'est pas ça se passe le problème on
parle d'un fonds européens pour financer
les opérations extérieures
c'est pour demain se font mousser pour
la st la saint glinglin c'était c'était
prévu dans le traité il ya cinq ans mais
n'a jamais été mis en place
donc les réponses à la crise qui est
passée par là qui a publié à la crise
elle a créé le budget coupé ce sont les
jets de la défense dès qu'on parle de
financement effectivement c'est les
premiers vous devez couper
automatiquement ceux de la défense mais
c'est ce qu'il est plus facile de couper
régulièrement parce que globalement les
militaires se plaignent pas ils vont pas
descendre dans la rue mais présent dans
tous les pays
et puis ils vont faire avec ce qu'ils
ont disponibles pour faire le mieux
possible mais du coup on a ce que des
chercheurs appellent les armes et bonsaï
mais effectivement la moitié des pays
européens n'ont plus qu'une armée qui
est bonne à faire des défilés le jour de
la fête nationale envoyé trois
observateurs dans une mission de l'onu
parce que dans les missions de l'onu
s'est payé par l'onu point à la ligne
c'est tout le problème européen
aujourd'hui des là effectivement la
crise financière est passée par là et du
coup un manque d'appétence politique et
surtout ne faisons rien et comme ça on
est tranquille et sur l'europe de la
défense donc on en parle il y en a qui
disent qu'elle elle aura lieu à lieu
jamais ce que vous pensez qu'un jour on
aura des forces européennes voir le jour
il ya quelques l horizon qu'est ce qui
bloque saadé ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
europe de la défense
en fait aujourd'hui avec la crise
économique en fait elle va avoir lieu je
pense plus vite que prévu tout
simplement sous l'effet de la pression
des plans l'annnonce de ads de 6000
suppressions d'emplois a sonné à mon
avis comme un coup de cloche est un cri
d'alarmé c'est à dire que l'industrie de
la défense
concrètement représentent des emplois
donc en fait elle viendra par l'économie
elle viendra pas parle opérationnel pour
l'instant parce qu'effectivement ce qui
bloque dans l'opérationnel c'est c'est
c'est un risque politique très clair
faut savoir qu'en france on a moins de
risques mais il faudra que la plupart
des pays sont en coalition
et ils doivent avoir l'autorisation de
leur gouvernement et souvent de leur
parlement il faut savoir que par le
gouvernement néerlandais quand même
tombé à cause de l'intervention en
afghanistan on l'oubli donc on a
l'impression tout va bien et que pour
les autres et aucun problème il ya qu'en
france quasiment ou sur un coup de
sifflet du chef d'état tout le monde y
va ce sera le mot de la fin en tout cas
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
maintenant place à place aux reportages
la prostitution faut-il punir les
clients alors que la france est en train
voter une loi qui sanctionne les clients
des prostituées à quelle législation
sont soumis les autres pays européens
nous allons en suède pour voir comment
ça marche la suède c'est le pays où la
pénalisation du client est en route
depuis 1999 et vous allez voir là bas
les policiers passent leur temps à
traquer les clients des prostituées pour
les verbaliser dans les rues de
stockholm
envoyé spécial à dans les rues de
stockholm arabi k
il est à peine 16 heures les rues de
stockholm sont déjà plongés dans le noir
pour jonas c'est le début d'une longue
tournée pendant des heures ce policier
en civil va sillonner les rues à la
recherche de clients de prostituées des
endroits où l'on peut trouver des
prostituées de ce côté là ici et de
l'autre des prostituées devenu quasiment
invisible alors qu'il y a quinze ans sur
ces mêmes trottoirs des centaines de
filles arpenter les rues mais depuis
1999 la législation suédoise pénalise
les amateurs de relations tarifées alors
les prostituées attendent discrètement
leurs clients au coin des rues avant de
les emmener quelques mètres plus loin à
l'abri des regards
c'est un cimetière de stockholm où les
prostituées emmènent leurs clients
pourtant la prostitution est loin
d'avoir disparu
en suède si le client est pénalisé les
prostituées sont considérées comme des
victimes et ne risque rien alors elles
sont nombreuses à vendre leurs charmes
sur internet
martin 34 ans est un des rares zones à
se prostituer
depuis deux semaines il vend ses
services sur internet il a accepté de
nous rencontrer dans l'anonymat
la loi ne l'a pas empêché de vendre son
corps selon lui elle est inutile et
n'empêcherait pas les réseaux de
prospérer la loi n'empêchera pas les
proxénètes et les violences les
acheteurs ou du sexe existeront toujours
et aucune loi ne peut changer ça même
constat pour cette association qui
travaille avec les prostituées
la loi serait un échec
selon nous la loi devrait cibler
davantage le proxénétisme et les filles
que l'on force à se prostituer
nous ne pensons pas que cette loi de
pénalisation du client soit efficace au
royaume scandinave
les clients de prostituées sont des
délinquants sexuels que l'on peut
soigner des clients condamnés souvent
marié père de famille viennent pousser
discrètement les portes de ce centre
public gratuit un lieu dead et d' écoute
ou maria johnson psychothérapeute
spécialiste en addiction sexuelle les
reçoit
bessad veiller à la war z publicité la
jaune là à la mécène pub dans le journal
est ce que vous payez pour des relations
sexuelles
est-ce que vous surfez sur des sites
pornographiques vous voulez arrêter ils
se sentent coupables ils se sentent maj
ils ont peur ils ont honte parce qu'ils
ont honte auprès des prostituées qu'ils
ont payé ils ont un taiseux sentent
coupables par rapport à leurs familles
et ils sont anxieux car ils ont pas
envie de le faire marien se félicite de
ces résultats
80 % de ces patients ou ne verrait plus
de prostituées selon un rapport publié
en 2011
la chatte actes sexuels auraient diminué
de moitié depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi les clients pris en flagrant
délit et une amende proportionnelle à
leurs revenus qui représente
généralement la moitié de leur salaire
et depuis 2011
il risque même la prison mais pour
l'instant cette peine n'a jamais été
appliquée au grand regret de cette
militante féministe strain auquel rails
avec une amende le roy on peut se cacher
personne ne peut savoir vous avez été
punis alors que si vous devez aller en
prison c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
le cacher alors je pense que ça serait
beaucoup plus dissuasif
mais la pénalisation du client serait
une grande avancée et aurait même
contribué à faire changer la mentalité
suédoise houacine cornes que 30% des
années pensé qu'il était normal
d'acheter une relation sexuelle alors
que maintenant celui pour cent des
hommes le pense oui
ce chiffre baisse dans cet amour si
certains crient victoire
pour d'autres la suède n'a fait que
déplacer le problème vers les pays
voisins selon une étude 70 % des suédois
ayant payé pour des relations sexuelles
affirme l'avoir fait à l'étranger
voilà c'était un reportage de rabih
kayrouz ou rejoint sur ce plateau nicole
kiil nielsen bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputée française du groupe écologie
et les verts avec plusieurs de vos
collègues européens vous êtes signataire
de l'appel de bruxelles qui demande à
tout pays d'abolir la prostitution à vos
côtés cécile cérons bonjour vous êtes
coordinatrice de l'association ace
aspects pour espace prostituées à
l'association belge qui fête ses 25 ans
et qui vient en aide aux travailleurs du
sexe elle a rédigé elle aussi un
manifeste demandant notamment que l'
embauche des prostituées soient
dépénalisées et contrôler que de réel
droit soit accordée aux indépendants
qu'il soit possible de quoi exploiter à
l'utt prostitution sans que cela ne soit
assimilée à du proxénétisme ou encore
que le client ne soient pas pénalisés
alors mesdames vous venez de voir ce
reportage de radis cas on al impression
qu en pénalisant le client on fragilise
quelque part les prostituées qui qui se
cache que tout devient clandestins
est-ce que les fragilise pas au bout les
continents mais je pense qu'actuellement
les personnes prostituées sont
fragilisés je crois que c'est d'abord ça
le constat la personne prostituée qui se
retrouve seul avec un client qui est
libre de disposer de son corps et de
finalement de faire ce qu'il veut de
cette personne est fragilisée donc je
crois qu'il faut pas d'abord posé la
question à partir de l'état des lieux
actuel et concernant la fragilisation
par la loi je n'y crois pas beaucoup
parce que beaucoup de personnes
prostituées suédoise disque depuis qu'il
y à cette loi elles se sentent en
sécurité avec des clients puisque vous
l'avez vu la prostitution est toujours
pratiquée mais beaucoup moins qu'ils ont
peur d'être dénoncé auprès de la police
donc en fait elle se sent protégé par
cette loi
donc je ne crois pas là à cet argument
de fragilisation ceci et gérons
pénaliser le client c'est la solution
c'est pas la solution parce qu'en fait
il ya pas deux personnes prostituées qui
se ressemblent il n'y a pas de clients
qui se ressemblent non plus et donc s'il
ya en effet des tattes personnes
prostituées fragilisé par ce que par
exemple victimes de toxicomanie ou quoi
il n'ya pas que ces personnes-là aux
victimes de la traite
on a aussi des personnes extrêmement
forte qui met un cadre à leur activité
qui donne sens à leurs activités
et donc à partir du moment où elles
doivent se cacher elles sont à ce
moment-là fragilisé par ce qu'elles ne
peuvent plus faire appel aussi
facilement à des collègues où elles sont
plus éloignés aussi des associations des
messages de prévention
donc le modèle suédois la france ce sens
en espérant on va faire quoi alors on va
dire aux policiers d'aller faire du
flagrant délit de d'aller traquer le
client et les prostituées sur le fait on
va d'abord dire et pour moi c'est
fondamental dans cette loi française on
va dire aux jeunes garçons et aux jeunes
filles de france qu'il cookies ne sont
pas autorisés à vendre ou acheter le
corps d'une autre personne
je pense que cette loi est là c'est une
avancée historique pour les droits des
femmes
je moi je lassitude dans ce contexte
vous savez on a connu dans l'histoire
le droit de cuissage qui a été aboli le
viol qui en france et dans beaucoup de
pays est criminalisé y compris le viol
dans le couple eh bien là c'est le
dernier maillon de cette évolution pour
les droits des femmes
on ne peut pas acheter le corps des
femmes je crois que la loi elle a une
fonction normative très importante pour
qu'on parvienne un jour à une société
égalitaire entre les hommes et les
femmes
et c'est ça qui est important d'abord
cette loi elle va elle doit avec le
temps c'est pas une baguette magique
bien entendu elle doit et on le voit
bien en suède faire évoluer les
mentalités faire évoluer les relations
entre les hommes et les femmes entre les
petits garçons les petites filles dès le
plus jeune âge moi je viens d'éducation
nationale et j'ai par exemple beaucoup
travaillé contre le racisme et la loi
qui dit que le racisme est interdit par
la loi bien ça m'a servi c'est quelque
chose d'important de dire la loi pour
former les jeunes donc moi je crois
d'abord que c'est cela qu'il faut voir
dans cette toile en france il est prévu
évidemment que les personnes qui
souhaitent quitter la prostitution
seront accompagnés et moi je rends
hommage à toutes les associations
évidemment qui s'occupe des personnes
prostituées parce que les personnes
prostituées
ils et elles ne se ressemblent pas ce
sont quand même pour une grande majorité
dans toute l'europe des femmes
d'abord ce sont une grosse majorité de
femmes et les clients se ressemblent
parce que ce sont majoritairement des
hommes
donc il ya là un problème qui on peut
appeler la domination masculine
mon objectif c'est effectivement de
faire évoluer les choses et de d'aboutir
à une société où il n'y est plus et de
domination masculine
donc j'ai remporté mon partager ce point
de vue pour mais non justement c'est là
que le bât blesse c'est que le lobby
abolitionniste est vraiment dans un
combat pour défendre des valeurs à bout
ce soliste c'est à dire ceux qui veulent
abolir la prostitution vous êtes plutôt
réglementariste a dit réglementée à pelé
s'être dans un bain dans un combat
contre à cette amitié pour vous c'est
pas une atteinte à la dignité
c'est à dire qu'on ne veut pas se lancer
dans un combat pour défendre des valeurs
en disant ça c'est bien ça c'est mal
mais plutôt pourrait pourrait être
améliorée des conditions de vie des
personnes concernées
c'est quoi ces conditions de vie
racontée vous êtes sur le terrain à vous
c'est quoi on fait de la prostitution
parce que c'est des jeux d'abord un
problème économique c'est d'abord il ya
des situations locales donc je crois que
dans chaque pays on perd dans des
situations différentes moi je ne
parlerai que de ce que je tenais à le
salir en belgique on se rend compte par
exemple que on a plus que 30% de femmes
belges que dans les personnes migrantes
comme on les appelle non belges on a
majoritairement des femmes d'europe de
l'ouest les femmes qui viennent de
france parce que il ya la répression
dans leur pays des femmes qui sont
surtout poussé par le fait qu'elles ont
perdu leur travail parce qu'elles sont
victimes de surendettement
parce qu'elles ont par exemple été
victime d'une escroquerie elles se
retrouvent avec des dettes donc des
problèmes financiers importants et donc
leur fragilisation elle vient là la
vraie cause le plus souvent c'est les
problèmes d'argent évidemment et donc je
me dis faut pas se combattre se
confondre et se tromper de menly l'aîné
s'est laissé la crise c'est les
mauvaises conditions de vie notamment
aussi dans les pays africains où on a
des femmes qui ont choisi vous
tous les deux ravis cas lors de son
reportage a interviewé la présidente
lgbt suède qui est contre cette loi qui
punit le client elle dit pourquoi on
l'écouté vous réagissez juste après
si l'on se fie à nos observations ainsi
qu'aux études d'autres organisations
spécialisées
la prohibition a entraîné l'apparition
de nouveaux problèmes de nouvelles
violences les prostituées par exemple
disent qu'elles rencontrent plus de
difficultés ça pourrait être suivi par
les services de santé
voilà est-ce qu en punissant les clients
fragiles disent pas les prostituées
elles disent qu'elles ont ainsi accès
aux soins
la loi française justement ne se
contente pas de dire qu'on va pénaliser
les clients
elle prévoit justement un accompagnement
et un renforcement du financement des
associations pour aider les personnes
prostituées à la fois un accompagnement
sanitaire social et formation
professionnelle pour sortir de la
prostitution
il est même prévu un titre de séjour
pour les personnes d'origine étrangère
sur ce qu'on oublie de dire c'est que la
grande majorité des personnes
prostituées en europe ce sont des
personnes d'origine étrangère il y a un
lien évident et le parlement européen
là-dessus a pris une position très
claire entre la prostitution et la
traite des êtres humains
donc il s'agit bien de mettre fin à un
trafic d'êtres humains qui rapporte
énormément d'argent
c'est après le trafic d'armes et le
trafic de drogue c'est le trafic des
êtres humains qui rapporte le plus
d'argent et le lit alors qu'ils sont en
punissant le client veut responsabiliser
de lui dire que celle qu est ce qui
intéresse les proxénètes et les réseaux
c'est pas le sexe c'est l'argent et
l'argent il vient d'où du client de
consommateurs donc il faut que les
choses soient très claires il faut
responsabiliser les citoyens et leur
dire quand il achète le service sexuel
ils sont complices du trafic sur le
terrain qu'est ce qu'elle vous dise
les travailleuses du sexe ce qu'elles
nous disent est ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'elles ne sont pas majoritairement
victimes de la traite ou ne sont pas
quand on entend des chiffres de 80% de
victimes de la traite
nous en tout cas c'est parce que ça
correspond pas à ce qu'on ressent et
c'est normal ne doivent pas le dire on a
une personne
on en france une personne prostituée
très célèbre de lyon qui est sorti
maintenant de la prostitution est dit
comment avez vous pu me croire parce
qu'à l'époque elle était dans les médias
comment avez vous pu me croire quand je
disais que je n'étais pas pour le mac
est celle des armes qu'elle utilise
l'écran mais voilà parce que
effectivement il ya une grande de
pressions et menaces y ont aussi tué
billy tan tan disant comment est-ce
qu'on nous retire le droit de nous
exprimer et comment est-ce qu'on ne
donne pas crédit à notre parole ça
concerne une minorité les personnes qui
choisissent ça comme profession et vous
savez très bien que en france comme en
belgique les françaises et les belges ne
propose pas leurs propres enfants
d'exercer cette profession dans les
collèges dans les lycées on ne propose
pas aux enfants de choisir cette
profession c'est pas un projet de vie
c'est quand même comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même une conséquence de la crise ça
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
on voit bien en espagne par exemple de
plus en plus d'étudiantes maintenant
qu'ils pratiquent la prostitution parce
que la crise économique est terrible
mais je veux dire il faut pas présenter
cette pratique comme une solution moi
j'assume
vous vous êtes à vue à bougie sioniste
pourquoi vous auriez pu être dedans dans
l'autre camp c'est à dire est
réglementée dire que cet ami steve vous
l'aimez regard il faut lui mettre des
noms mais enfin ça peut pas être
considéré comme un métier en allemagne
il y actuellement quatre cent mille
personnes qui pratiquent la prostitution
chaque jour on parle d'un million de
clients par jour
et la gagnante huile en france puis
l'allemagne est actuellement en train de
remettre en cause et de réfléchir à un
autre système parce que l'allemagne est
devenue le terrain privilégié du
tourisme sexuel c'est vraiment
formidable c'est pas cher on a des
jeunes femmes sont les suivantes pour
conclure moi ça fait 25 ans que j'écoute
les dames dans la prostitution et donc
je me dis mais je ne sais pas - si
j'étais dans une situation où mes
enfants n'ont pas accès aux soins mes
enfants n'ont pas accès à l'école si je
ne me prostitueraient pas en tant qu'on
n'est pas passé par certains
d'innovation et chorale on se rassure
donc ça c'est une chose
ce que les femmes nous disent aussi
c'est qu'il ya quand même une forte
pression des clients pour des passants
préservatifs et je voudrais quand même
rappeler les recommandations du sida et
d'une hutte qui est le programme des
nations unies pour le développement
10 pas de pénalisation de la
prostitution parce que les femmes vont
être beaucoup plus enclines à accepter
des passants préservatifs à partir du
moment où elles doivent se cacher et
qu'elles ont elles ont moins facilement
des clients pour payer leurs factures je
suis pas correct vous mettra pas
d'accord en tout cas en tout cas merci
d'avoir dax accepter notre à notre
invitation c'est la fin d'europe hebdo
on nous on se retrouve le mois prochain
d'ici là passez de bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année est resté avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires